Finding long lost relatives can be really tricky, especially if you don't
have a good place to start. But it's a lot easier if you
have the help from someone like a genetic genealogist. And today we're lucky
enough to be joined remotely with CeCe Moore, a genetic genealogist. Hi CeCe.
>> Hi Matt, how are you?
>> I'm doing pretty good.
>> you know we're pretty excited to be learning all about this
ancestry and human evolution and we're really curious at this point, you know,
what is it that a Genetic Genealogist does?
>> A Genetic Genealogist uses DNA testing in conjunction with
traditional genealogy research in order to learn more about our roots.
>> How far out do you go in a family structure as a
Genetic Genealogist? Are you interested in, you
know, up to grandparents and maybe second
cousins, or do you, do you, do you build out farther than that? Do
you connect whole families? Kind of just give us some idea of how far
out you go.
>> Well, we're interested in our family trees as
far back as we can go. So with Y-DNA
testing, which has been used in genetic genealogy much
longer than autosomal DNA tests like 23 and Me.
We're looking way back, we could be looking back
into the 1400's even, because as you know, the
Y chromosome changes very slowly therefore a father and
son will probably have an identical Y chromosome, and
maybe a grandparent and a great grandparent, a
second great grandfather on that direct paternal line. So
we've used these surname studies to go many, many
generations back, centuries back. With Autosomal DNA we're not
looking quite so far back, because of the recombination.
However, when we first started using Autosomal DNA for
genetic genealogy, we were told that it was only
going to work maybe five generations, six generations back.
And especially with our adoption DNA research,
we have proven that it works much further
back. We're able to identify ancestral couples
a couple centuries ago, actually in these trees.
And the way we do that is for instance, if an adoptee knows nothing about their
biological heritage we would take all of their family trees of their DNA matches
so, everyone who's willing to share at 23 and
Me or family tree DNA, of ancestry DNA. We would
start comparing those trees looking for commonalities and intersections among
their matches trees, since they don't know anything about their
family tree, and if we see a certain ancestry
tree couple over and over and over and over, we
can be pretty sure that, that's probably one of their
ancestors as well. And if not their ancestor, certainly in
an ancestral line, one of their branches of
their family tree would have that ancestral line in
it. And we've used couples very far back, like
late 1600's, 1700's and been able to build down
to the present time. That takes a lot of
work, believe me, and we wouldn't just do it
with one couple. We would do it with various
couples, build their descendants down to the present and
try to see where there's intersections between the
descendants from those ancestral couples and if we can
do that, which we sometimes can, we can
sometimes solve these adoption search cases without a close
relative match. If we get second cousin or
closer, we can almost always solve it. if we're
only working with third cousins, fourth cousins, fifth
cousins, and more distant, it takes a lot more
work, but it has been done.
>> Great, CeCe, it's been a pleasure chatting with you. I hope
you'll join us again, in maybe the discussion forums for our course.
>> That would be great, I'd love to.